I'm the Alice timepiece that I've never
been Nova Scotia Nova Scotia and this is
Halifax the start of my journey keys
please I'm headed for Cape Breton Island
to experience from some of the people
there
what makes this pass the world so unique
[Music]
salmon fishing has been part of the
fabric of the Mercury's all right back
to 1865 what I enjoy most about it is
the people that I meet and the ability
to introduce you to the river the views
throughout here at Miller's majestic
it's very very rugged but at the same
time it has an incredible interview to
it that's probably my main source of
inspiration it's a city of my friend
Stephan Washington Sacha
[Music]
this is the home of North America's
first single monthly
the environment here is clean pristine
natural wheel the people here are
beautiful kind people
you come out here and people always
think feel like you're at home and ie
and I have found anything quite as
feeling like home
that's called scotia all right my job is
very highly moist is check it out - big
place in about three minutes that was
massive it's a slower pace and there's a
lot to be said for living somewhere
where the pace is slow it's always such
a comfortable feel here no matter where
you go he's still sort of feel like
you're in your own hometown I get to
live and and do what I love in a place
that's so beautiful and just so great
[Music]
nova scotia thanks very much
[Music]
you